[Musica]
[Applauso]
mi vedete così con lo sguardo fiero e
cattivo mentre segni un touchdown per la
nazionale italiana di football americano
a testa alta petto in fuori orgogliosa e
fiera di ciò che ho appena fatto sembra
indistruttibile no
eppure non sono nata forte e non ero
coraggiosa quando ero bambino Nata È
cresciuta a Milano l'ultima di cinque
figli Volevo disperatamente essere
nuotata e amata dai miei genitori dovevo
essere la bambina perfetta e aggraziata
che volevano che fossi come se la mia
esistenza dipendesse da questo come se
senza la loro approvazione non esistesse
affatto
Volevano che fossi elegante e che non
occuparsi spazio stai ferma lì zitte
buone Nausica così mi hanno spinto a
prendere lezioni di danza di ginnastica
e io le ho Accontentati l'unica
decisione che ho preso da sola è stata
quella di entrare in una squadra di
cheerleaders a 16 anni volevo gareggiare
come le ragazze ponpani in America
volevo fare le piramidi umani e le
evoluzioni in pedana ma alla fine mi
sono trovata in un team di che leaders
che invece di gareggiare faceva il tifo
quindi ancora una volta
stavo facendo quello che la società si
aspetta dalle donne nello sport stare a
bordo campo a guardare i ragazzi
urlando solo quando necessario senza
disturbarli zitta e buona nel mio caso
lo sport che ammiravo da Bordo campo era
il football americano e ogni weekend
guardavo i ragazzi giocare è partita
dopo partita questo sport ha acceso un
fuoco dentro di me volevo entrare in
campo Volevo placcare volevo ricevere
volevo lanciare volevo giocare a
football Ero stufa dei pon pon e come me
tantissime altre ragazze Nello Stadio
erano stanche di stare a guardare Alcune
erano cheerleaders altre erano sorelle
dei giocatori fidanzate cugine volevamo
scendere in campo ma questa opzione 12
anni fa non esisteva
quindi siamo andati dal proprietario
della squadra super entusiasta e piene
di speranza presidente presidente
vogliamo creare la prima squadra di
football americano in Italia
ci brillavano gli occhi ma lui scoppiò a
ridere quello che gli americani chiamano
the dream chocolate la risata di quelli
che ridono dei tuoi sogni
volessi giocare a football Voi siete il
sesso debole per un motivo vi farete
male non sapete neanche giocare a calcio
figuriamoci a football non se ne parla
voi in questo campo non giocherete mai a
testa bassa siamo uscite da
quell'ufficio in silenzio Ma io non
volevo più stare zitta è buona volevo
essere ascoltata volevo creare caos così
abbiamo trovato un coach disposto ad
allenarci ci ha portato al parco di
Sempione di Milano dandoci le sue
attrezzature polverose degli anni 80 e
ben presto in quel parco da cinque siamo
diventate eventi le vichinghi Milano una
banda di sorelle pronte a fare di tutto
per realizzare il loro sogno il nostro
allenatore scoprì che a Bologna Stava
nascendo un'altra squadra e così
organizzo subito una partita il 30
luglio del 2011 in un campo di sabbia o
letteralmente di patate abbiamo giocato
la nostra prima partita Tutto ciò che
indossavamo ovviamente era enorme e
antiquato ma per noi era come giocare al
Super Bowl abbiamo vinto quella partita
ma soprattutto abbiamo vinto la
battaglia più importante il presidente
della nostra squadra cambia idea e
iniziò a investire nel football
femminile e anche la Federazione
Italiana di football americano lafidaf
Iniziò un incredibile campagna per
aiutare le donne a giocare a football
sempre di più da un campo di patate a
Bologna siamo passate ai Mondiali in
Israele e ai World Games in Alabama
haifaf la federazione internazionale e
la NFL National Football League ci hanno
dato gli strumenti per poter competere
ai massimi livelli e oggi il football
americano è giocato in più di 150 Paesi
nel mondo il football femminile
Se volete sapere la cosa più assurda di
questa storia
mio padre non voleva che io giocassi a
football era completamente contrario
diceva che
sarebbe stata una perdita di tempo per
me che
non sarei mai arrivata da nessuna parte
soprattutto che mi sarei fatta male
Eppure
quando tornavo dall'allenamento a casa e
lui mi picchiava
o mi faceva trovare la mia attrezzatura
i miei scarpini mio paraspalle nella
pattumiera
in quel momento mi feriva più di
qualsiasi infortunio che io abbia mai
subito sul campo Mi sono rotta due
crociati e un menisco giocando ma niente
niente niente niente niente
può essere Comparato a il dolore di una
persona che dovrebbe proteggerti e
amarti incondizionatamente e non lo fa e
decide di non farlo decide di ferirti
A proposito lui non sa ancora che io
gioco Non lo so Non lo so neanche oggi
perché purtroppo a volte l'approvazione
dei genitori non arriva mai
l'approvazione di chi vi circonda non
arriva ma bisogna accettarlo crearsi il
proprio mondo approvarsi da sole e
cercare supporto da chi è al vostro
stesso sogno
perché purtroppo quei genitori a volte
va così
farebbero di tutto per supportarti di
tutto
tranne che lasciarti essere te stesso
e quindi impari a rimanere in una
scatola ti insegno a stare schiscia Come
si dice a Milano a stare in silenzio
composta e a rimanere immobile zitta è
buono no perché se ti muovi crei caos e
perché se fai di testa tua hai seguito
cuore crei disordine e poi diventi un
problema no a un certo punto la mia
passione è diventata più importante più
forte della mia compiacenza è diventato
più importante
giocare a football
che cercare l'approvazione degli altri
il mio mondo è diventato il campo da
football dove le mie compagne sono la
mia famiglia Il campo è dove mi sento
più forte e tutti voi dovreste trovare
il vostro campo e il vostro casco e
iniziare a sfondare ogni ostacolo
davanti a voi e questo non solo nel
football Ma nella vita perché Football è
l'arte di rimanere in piedi quando tutti
cercano di buttarti giù e spesso ci
riescono e cadi Ma poi ti rialzi con
l'aiuto delle tue compagne e guardi
avanti e pensi all'azione dopo e quella
dopo ancora finché non raggiungi la meta
il touchdown questo non è solo il
football
Questa è la vita e nella vita se non
crei caos non cambia nulla se non metti
in disordine non troverai mai il tuo
ordine soprattutto se non abbracci
quello che sei quello che ami e apprezzi
la tua unicità sarai sempre sulla strada
sbagliata il football mi ha dato la
fiducia necessaria per parlarvi oggi per
trasmettervi tutto quello che ho dentro
e per raccontarvi la mia storia il
football ha cambiato la mia vita e oggi
sta cambiando la vita di milioni di
ragazze in tutto il mondo la crescita È
incredibile ma possiamo fare di più
anche col vostro aiuto tutti insieme
ognuno di voi può far crescere lo sport
femminile in generale ognuno di voi può
aiutare il mondo a cambiare la sua
percezione delle donne nello sport
perché solo insieme abbiamo
l'opportunità di creare nuovi percorsi e
modelli da seguire per mostrare alle
ragazze e alle donne che non possono il
football è un posto nel mondo che siamo
forti e che non c'è nessuna ragione di
stare zitte e buone quando siamo nate
per distinguerci e per farci sentire
[Musica]